all right what's goody Hopper at the
verse welcome back to Hot Breath the
show where you learn comedy from the
pros
today
is an episode from our weekly live
stream we do every Tuesday on our
YouTube channel and Facebook group where
we answer your questions live on the air
my co-host Yoshi so and I are here to
help you level up your comedy game
and the first guest we have up you ready
for this Yoshi
I've been ready I was born ready let's
go baby I'm a little nervous but
nervousness this is this is next level
this is next level so one second
we're gonna bring her on live there's
Yoshi all right here we go
yeah ladies and gentlemen oh my God
what's happening it's Victoria
yeah
let's go
I'm so honored
you're the first official guest on hot
breath live Ah that's amazing I look
horrible though but whatever anyway
what's up you look great
you look great you're talking to two
great guys we'll never say otherwise
[Laughter]
yeah yes do you want it you want
feedback on a joke
sure is it is it um very PG because it
has the word sex in it that's fine oh
yeah you're good we're good
my husband
I think my husband really likes makeup
sex so much so that I think he fights
with me just for the makeup sex
the other day we had a huge fight
and he was inching closer to me in bed
and I was like dude
the only way you're gonna get near it is
if you swipe a credit card through it
and it keeps declining because I keep
changing the pin number
[Laughter]
23 years
you've been married for 23 years yeah 24
next week yeah
okay congrats
yeah congrats I like this joke I like
um
I like the premise and I love the punch
line I'd probably say the first thing on
my mind is how do we get to closer into
the part where you get to the setup a
little quicker it was just a lot of lead
up all the way up to that part but
outside of that it's pretty solid I like
it because it's just the whole switching
PIN numbers is very very funny thank you
I actually have a I have five shows
coming up this weekend
um for uh I'm featuring so it's 30
minutes nice
comedian named give me Thalia
who who Jimmy Jimmy fallia he's on uh
Gutfeld a lot oh god he's a stand-up
comic and also a um uh you know like a
guy that goes on you know like a
commentator type of commentary type of
guy so I'm excited about that and uh
yeah I just I'm trying I'm writing every
single day every single my brain is just
Twitter is just a snapshot of my brain
and that's her own all my premises go
and if my husband laughs at a joke then
I know I could use it in a bit because
he doesn't laugh at anything and he's
been to five of my shows in 12 years
like oh yeah yeah he doesn't care or he
doesn't he's like just do your thing
whatever it is have your little comedy
enjoy
I like this
he could say whatever he wants
wants the bills
my little Hobby
or you're putting in the work so it's
it's paying off and I I like almost you
starting that joke with you being
married for so long I feel like it's
like almost like after after 24 years of
marriage
us having my something about like our
sex life is like trying to swipe a
credit card
and then now there's an analogy setup of
like you can find different examples of
a credit card and one of them could be
you keep changing the pin number
um
it's going to be expired soon and stuff
declined declined yeah that's what I
said before yeah yeah yeah I'm wondering
I I like the way I start the joke only
because I don't I want I don't want to
give away the punchline too early like
the punch line one of the punch lines I
love the tags but one of the punch lines
is the only way you're getting near it
is if you swipe a credit card through it
oh no that's right yeah I'm not saying
the actual word but you know you get the
idea
because this is because because there's
a slit all right it doesn't you know
what I mean
on Valentine's Day here's a here's um I
also say make sure that this is one of
those things that's definitely like it
can get lost
no no I can't get lost like just make
sure that there's a punch line for each
part of the premise right so like the
beginning of the joke is about your
husband and how uh
he gets into fights easily right or like
he wants to always get in the fight I
think he's fighting with me to get the
makeup set like now it's starting to now
Montana yeah it's like yeah like I would
connect the two my husband fights with
me to get the makeup sex but it's gonna
cost him now you're going to get credit
card
my whole Act is basically me doing
whatever I want him paying all the bills
because we don't have a prenup so
no really no really that's the truth
no really we had a huge fight once and
in the middle of the fight he was he was
like you don't work all I do is work
because I took care of the kids and now
they're in school so that I'm retired
early what should I do so he says you
don't work all I do is work for you I
said oh my God I asked you what I was
good at you said I was great at
complaining I don't shut the f up I
think I nailed it I'm doing exactly what
I should be doing and then I said do you
really feel like that he goes yes I feel
like all I do is work for you and I said
oh my God honey you're right we don't
have a prenup break time's over we said
you could talk to your bosses wrapping
up and I really said that to him and he
started laughing I mean it could have
gone another way but once he started
laughing I said all right I'm putting
that on my uh
my whole entire humor is basically like
kind of Joan riversy he works I just do
what I want that type of thing he's a
sucker that's where our that's my whole
Act
and then I make fun of the kids because
they are taking all the money that he's
given me you know what I'm saying like
that's solid no no I like it I think
just put the two ideas together I like
that I like that add-on that because now
it makes more sense
I mean it's it's in my repertoire anyway
you know what I mean like it's in there
but but it really does point it out
because if you're just walking in to the
club at that time or the act at that
time they don't know what my premises
are in the whole act exactly so it's
better to just have every joke be a joke
separately even if they don't know who I
am and they're just walking and that's
how I like to watch a comic like like
there are Comics that get on stage I
mean I run an open mic every weekend and
they do oh I'm just visiting New York
and I'm like
where you from like they don't even say
where they're from I'm like I need
context you know like give me some
content by the way you guys are always
invited on a show with my on my shows in
uh Broadway Comedy Club when I I produce
shows there so of course I mean yeah
whenever we make a New York trip we'll
definitely be there let me know ahead of
time and I'll uh I'll put you on my show
I usually get a pack show so it's fun I
love it yeah but that's a good joke
thank you yeah and I love how you're
already self-aware of like your persona
and such too so you kind of know where
your comedy's coming from that's great
yeah I mean I was like you know what do
I want to tie myself into a theme but
yeah you know what I do I do because it
really is my life I'm doubling down on
what I know
for sure yeah exactly I mean I imaginate
of course you know like I'm I'm
exaggerating a lot of it it's like you
know very desperate housewife type of
thing but it's really the truth is it's
uh it's fun to play on because that's my
character that I'm that I'm doubling
down
congrats yeah great jokes
[Music]
why now and I'll get off but I think
once you have a theme it doesn't matter
what even what the jokes are like they
kind of all you know it all kind of
threads together and then and it becomes
like not too mechanical because it's
already part of the whole Persona that's
what I think
okay
um you know I got banned on Instagram uh
and then
oh yeah because you know the joke was a
good one it was good you want to hear it
anyway
um
it wasn't a photo it was a joke no it
was it was a photo of a tweet and then I
made it into a tick tock and then I put
the Tweet was fine when I did it but
when I did it in a video they were like
no
they were not okay but anyway it was a
really good joke I'll tell you another
time but listen in person I'll tell you
but uh my new my Instagram is where I'm
at uh Victoria makes you laugh with the
y o u
and Twitter's Vicky on scene basically
Twitter's my my joke writing because it
has a certain amount of characters I
actually learned that from Mark Norman
Mark Norman was writing all these jokes
that then he would take it to the stage
I'm like oh it kind of limits you and it
cuts the fat so you could just do the
job and then like you could always add
on from there it's a great writing
method and you could also test it out
and you put it on Instagram and you
start sharing it at different places
very cool
how do you spell it Vicki arnstein yeah
my Twitter is Vicky v i c k y
ernstein is a-r-n-s-t-e-i-n
thanks guys and by the way remember to
more he opened for me and now he's huge
let's go TAMU is killing it I'm so proud
of him I know I'm so happy for him I
lived in Hawaii for seven years that's
why that's why I love it
thank you guys keep up the great work
love you I love your dedication we love
you too thanks Victoria
thank you bye
all right
and I'll just link to her Twitter
in the live chat
so if anyone else wants uh
we're not supposed to join us live next
I pinned a link
in
um in the live chat for y'all to join us
but that is a good interesting thing
about Persona and how she's like
self-aware of
her story what makes her unique how can
she write material from a place that no
one else could you know you and I being
married
we both have marriage material but it's
completely different because because
it's coming from a different place so
the same thing with anyone else trying
to kind of quote find their voice or
find their persona a big part of that is
just figuring out what's unique about
you where are you coming from
and then writing jokes from that space
absolutely yeah it takes a while to get
that your your voice and I think it's
either it's also one of those things
that like it's always evolving as well
so
you just gotta wait till it happens
yes
and as we wait till it happens for the
next person to join us I did post on our
Facebook group
about that was such a good segue I mean
come on
stuff solid stuff
they knew to this we grew to this fam
so I posted in our Facebook group where
we also do a daily uh joke writing
contest
where we post a new word and people
write new jokes and then we vote for
joke of the day in there
but I posted
a a thread about what questions do you
have what kind of Comedy questions you
have because we want to start you know
helping you out Beyond just like giving
joke feedback but also answering them
any questions you may have about your
comedy journey and there's a few in
there that I thought we could dive into
I think the first one to start with
I think this one got the most likes so I
think this is a good one to start with
but this is from James scouten and he
said how do you tweak stories add tags
delete Words Etc through performing how
many performances before you know
whether that change works or not
hmm
so I I'd probably say
I give uh most jokes about three chances
in terms of keep it in and in terms of
like not keeping it in like I'll try it
three times before I
shove a joke I don't get rid of it I'll
shelve it for a time where I'll save it
either for later or be like
I'll go review it after it's already
been done and then if Uh something's
working especially from a performance
perspective
I will actually do
it three times to make sure that it hits
every single time and then I'm like
that's a keeper and then I you know I
still grade my jokes like is it is this
a a joke is this a b laugh joke or is
even like a c job and then when I'm
performing like a headlining set or like
a feature set
all the A's and B's sort of just go up
to the top and that's like my set all
the C's I'll fill sometime in the middle
every once in a while just to see if I
can give some traction out of them but a
feature and a headline set is mostly my
A and B material
I hope that helped
yeah yeah and there's no just like with
anything there's no like comedy law
there's no like one way to do it at the
end of the day I mean there's no right
way there's only your way at the end of
the day so some people I've heard say
they try it three times some people 20
times 10 times you know like it's all
kind of personal preference on if it's a
joke you believe in and you really think
there's something there
then keep trying it until it works but I
will say a lot of the times like Yoshi
said shelving a joke so you can revisit
that joke with fresh eyes and fresh
perspective can really help you to start
finding the funny within that joke so
you may try it
five times and be like it's just not
hitting quite yet put it to the side
come back to it and even just like a
week put it come back to it in a month
or you know sometimes six months a year
later a joke will roll back around so
just because it's not working right now
it doesn't mean it won't ever yeah and
sometimes I just sometimes think maybe
you're not ready to do that joke yet
maybe like I also be like your skill set
isn't at the point where that joke is
really going to hit like that and I
think about that when um I think uh
might have been Seinfeld he talks about
the more daring your joke is the better
the payoff better be like it's kind of
like this like X and Y axis if you're
gonna go uh like controversial the
payoff better be like amazing I think
about that on some some types of jokes
that I write is that if the payoff isn't
great then I'm not ready to write that
joke yet it's just I'm just waiting and
sometimes you almost got to let it
marinate for a little bit like you said
like you know put it in the fridge and
then come back to it maybe a couple
weeks later
yep indeed so yeah I hope that helps
there James
um but it's all super incremental I mean
because he talked about tags and
deleting words and stuff like yeah
everything is super incremental like I
mean it takes months and years to
develop a joke and it just these little
nuances and these these little tweaks
just happen over time and repetition of
doing it on stage so it's it's all very
incremental comedy is definitely a
marathon so and it just it at the end of
the day it takes time but set yourself
up to develop it faster by you perform
but you also record and review your set
and that'll help the jokes to develop
faster
but that's all part of the that's all
part of the work that people don't want
people want to do crowd work go viral
and then boom but part of that invisible
work is you're grinding it out writing
jokes performing them reviewing them
refining them and then performing them
again so that's kind of that invisible
work of Comedy that
you know these Young Guns get lost every
now and then
that's the reality of it exactly yeah
yeah but great question there James
awesome question
well done nice uh and the other one that
I thought was interesting because I
think this one's very uh relevant as
well
is uh Judah Rosenstein asked is any
topic off limits in comedy
now my take on this
is the short answer is no but
it has to be
say it with me class
funny
it has to be funny no topic is off
limits as long as it's funny and I think
a lot of young Comics see someone like a
Bill Burr or like a Louis CK saying wild
things and they are uproariously
hilarious and then a young comic sees
that as like oh I'm gonna go say
something wild and then someone gets
offended and they're like oh a free
speech comedy it's like nah these dudes
worked three decades to figure out how
to make these crazy things funny so I
don't think a topic is off limits
but it has to be funny and I think
comics will help you get to these un
like these crazy topics
start with just mundane things like how
can you make your dog funny how can you
make your job funny start with just
figure out how to make things funny and
then you can start to apply that to the
crazier more taboo topics but it that I
mean it just takes time
yes absolutely yeah uh that's the best
point you can't
if you can't make a good like traffic or
like a good Airline joke
don't shoot for plan b or abortion or
you know I'm saying like gun control
like just make every day like if you
can't make a good like I look like joke
about yourself
and you're like I just had you know just
did something with a girl blah blah blah
blah you're like dude you're you're just
not there yet so yeah I just think it's
kind of like that slow steady Pace you
got to know how to be funny regularly
before you get into that stuff but also
it's like what's the appeal of saying
those things anyway
that is those guys that is that Comics
like character Bill Byrne is a comedian
that
sort of thrives on that stuff but he
didn't start off that way he was just
straight up joke writing clean
writer kind of guy I think he did like
corporate gigs for a while he was
wearing the whole YouTube video about it
available now yeah yeah exactly right so
like you gotta you gotta crawl before
you walk you know I mean like you gotta
like you gotta get into the trenches so
yeah I would just saying it is not easy
just to go controversial right out of
the gate just write a mundane joke about
your day
and see if those get laughed and then
you can sort of elevate to all the other
stuff but then also you just got to be
very careful that you're your persona is
that what you want to be known as do you
want to be known as a controversial
comedian
or the comedian that says blue material
because if you're just a blue material
kind of comedian you're only going to
get work in blue rooms and there's not a
lot of blue rooms that are just like
yeah yeah we like a lot of blue material
this is all we do so this is kind of our
stuff clean comics get paid
regularly
[Laughter]
you're saying like super dirty Comics
can only work certain rooms yes you know
I understand if that's your character
and that's what you want to be but like
even super dirty comics
they got there from building like a fan
base
and so yeah I just said that's what you
want to be known as like versus who you
really are like if that's really who you
are then you know shoot for it but
yeah and I'm super mindful always of
like I never want to tell a comic what
to do or not to do on stage or what to
say or not to say at the end of the day
it's you up there say what I mean say
what your heart feels say what you think
is funny but I'm just telling you from
Context and professional experience of
over 13 years that it's like kind of
crawling before you walk will help you
to tackle those taboo topics with
success and not it bombs and you get mad
at the audience because you don't have
the skill set yet to make these things
funny that's why we do the the joke of
the day and the Facebook group every day
because it's literally like a word can
you make the word Valentine funny boom
write a joke using that it's just an
exercise to help you start thinking and
funny and then you can translate to
these taboo topics but I'm I'm by no
means I'm never like do this or don't do
this I only share from my personal
experience what I've learned and what
I've seen work for people and not work
for people
and it's it's your comedy Journey you
say and do whatever you want up there
but
it has to be say it with me class
funny
it has to have this
that it has to have that laugh on the
end of it
[Music]
but it's a great question
it's a great question
and uh another good one here and this
one can kind of actually apply to people
kind of later in their careers well Olga
one of our hot breath OG's uh from
Russia oh gee oh yeah
yeah and she asked um after how many
years in comedy
is it safe to quit without feeling like
a loser asking for a friend
[Laughter]
well
that's tough
and it's you know and there's nothing
wrong I mean if you're feeling this way
I mean I could tell you from personal
experience I mean
after the pandemic I'm like I was like
what am I doing because I mean like
pre-pandemic I was about to be a touring
headliner overnight I'm unemployed
and then like live shows are coming
we're starting to come back you know a
year or two later and I and I was at a
point of like well what am I
what is happening here what am I doing
and I think and I just talked to Steve
Byrne about this I just interviewed him
while he was in Atlanta and he's been
doing it 30 years
and I asked him about this feeling and
he was like we all go through that it's
kind of like the ups and downs of Comedy
you know it helps to remember why you
started and if you still have that
passion then keep going but there's also
nothing wrong with
not doing it for a while if you don't
feel like it
um Giannis Pappas we had him on the show
he talked about taking a break I think
he took like a year or two off
at some point in his career because he
he was just like I just gotta step away
so there's nothing there's nothing wrong
if it's like making you if it's comedy
should be fun and if it's bringing you
more
sadness than Joy then maybe it's time to
kind of step back a little bit you know
and I admit I did that with
pre-pandemic I was every show every
night grind grind grind and then after
like I've I haven't really I'll still do
open mics here and there I of course
still take the bookings available for
booking now anyone asking
but I don't necessarily feel that need
13 years in to be like oh I've got to do
three open mics a night now like and it
took me the pandemic 10 years into it to
realize oh maybe that's not part of like
my motivation anymore
um and that's something I had to reckon
with and I talked to you about that as
well Yoshi of like I feel I don't want
am I a comic for not wanting to go hate
myself at midnight on a Tuesday like
you know it's it's a mental thing we all
have to kind of battle with at all
levels you know so it's kind of a
personal preference there Olga
yeah yeah for sure I mean I'd probably
say that the simplest way to describe it
is that this is not
being a comic doesn't describe
everything that you are
therefore if you just want to take a
break from it that means you want to
take a break from it doesn't mean that
you're not successful doesn't mean
you're not the person that you want to
be it just means that this time comedy
is not the top priority for you and this
is a thing that I've learned honestly
dude like yeah last couple years of
therapy the pandemic of just sort of
defining yourself as this thing that you
are most of us are multiple things I'm a
father I'm a husband I do all these
other things I do work on the side like
but being a comedian isn't like
Define everything that I am so if I want
to take a break I can take a break if I
you know the things I can't take a break
from are like so much more important I
can't take a break from being a husband
I can't take a break from being a dad
like I can't take a break from paying
bills like those are the things that
like have to take priority for me so if
you have to take a break from Comedy
please take a break we don't need like
here's the thing we don't need people
who are about to break doing comedy you
know what I mean like
yeah
that I mean that's even you know I did
the right 10 Club live stream I did it
every day for over 400 days during the
pandemic and then I had like a breakdown
live on the air yeah I had to stop and
then and then I brought it and then I
brought it back trying to do it weekly
and the last one I did I was like I was
like uh oh I'm feeling myself going down
this this way again I was like just
leaning back in the chair like how long
can I do this I was like I didn't have a
crying breakdown like the one I did
during the pandemic but I was like all
right let's just step away let's just do
one live stream let's do this one and do
it well and it like you just it comes
down to like self-awareness
do what's best for you boo at the end of
the day
I like that yeah do what's best for you
yeah no that's I mean that's the truth
right there I mean I think uh comedy
isn't going away
just because you step away for a little
bit doesn't mean
really anything for the world of Comedy
would comedy love to have you back
absolutely but come back when you're
ready don't don't stay here and just be
like you know something comedy is
everything it's not it doesn't Define
you know we always joke about this is
like just remember you know that Joe
Rogan this is my favorite thing
doesn't get paid hundreds of millions of
dollars for being a comedian let's not
get that Twisted he's paid 100 million
dollars because he's really good at
podcasting
it's like
but is he a comedian he sure is
but that's not his top thing like you
know what I'm saying like what he's
spending time on is not like always
comedy he's been spending time on this
podcast thing been doing it for you know
10 years now it's just endlessly but is
he still writing jokes still doing all
that other stuff of course he is
but and now he's dedicating more time to
the comedies building a club and all
those other things so yeah there's any
moment you can step back step in it's
like a double dutch every once in a
while you just gotta you know get in
there and then you can come back out and
it's okay
um
it's personal yeah just personal
preference
more of these and these questions are
coming from our Facebook group where I
I'll do a post every week to gather your
questions and then we can answer them
live on the air here
um no but this is a good one and let's
try to get to these last two
um
uh um let's do Jacks first so Jack
another hot breath OG from across the
pond
across the point I don't know why I have
to go my accent to say that the pond uh
but he said what what's the right time
to move from a 10 minute set to a 15 to
20 minutes how many mics slash years I'm
nowhere near perfecting a 10 yet but
just curious for the future
is that when one of your 10 minutes is
hitting the mark consistently
a simple answer is you're always going
to be writing
if you're 10 minutes is has like the
kind of consistency that you're like
super satisfied with then for sure go to
15 12 15 whatever
I would say I'm always working on my 10
minute set always working on my five
minute set
it's a constant kind of thing but if
you've got just a solid 10 minutes and
you're killing it then yeah go on and
add more minutes to it
um but I think that some people think
that they have 20 minutes worth of
material they're like yeah I could do 20
minutes if you have 20 minutes worth of
material you can't do 20 minutes I hate
to say it
20 minutes worth of material you could
probably do like 10 minutes maybe like
like people that have like that are
headlining that's like 55 45 55 minutes
they have like an hour and a half of
material to get to 45 55 minutes
same thing even with smaller time if you
got 25 minutes worth of material that
means you could probably do like 15 to
20. just remember you need a lot of
material to get to that like a finite oh
yeah this is solid good stuff so if you
only have 10 minutes
don't be like oh I can do 10 minutes no
no no you almost need it's almost like I
don't know what the percentage number is
but if you have only 20 minutes of
material you could probably do maybe 10
to 15 minutes of time if you have 25
minutes of material you can probably do
15 minutes of time kind of like that
Gage I hope that helped yeah because
everyone can kill when they're all when
all the jokes are working
but
when it's when you're supposed to do 20
and that first joke doesn't work and you
have five tags after it that those
aren't gonna work they're like the
material shrinks real quick when the
jokes aren't working so you got to be
able to pull an audible and pivot and
shift
um but I will say
in terms of like performance side it's
like if you only have 10 minutes you're
thinking and someone offers you a 15
minute set
I say do it I mean because
I mean dude when I I headlined before I
should have and like I remember one of
the shows I ran out of material and I
started rubbing the walls and I was
rolling around on the ground
I was doing wildness to fill this time
and I didn't have it but those are the
moment like they they stretch you they
force you to rise to the occasion and
um so just if you say 10 minutes if
someone offers you a 15 minute set
I mean I I say do it or 20 minutes set I
mean I it maybe so I don't know though
dude I mean that's a personal preference
because if I'm booking someone
and I'm like can you do 20 and they say
I have 10.
that's a tough call man but I will say
I've taken gigs that I didn't have the
time but I did them anyway to kind of
force myself into that situation and
sometimes it worked out and sometimes it
didn't but I feel like I got stronger
either way
someone's willing to book you for that
time
just know that's one of those to Make It
or Break It moments right like we all
did headline gigs way before we were
probably ready and we all did like the
longer set gigs we're ready because it's
not like anyone's just giving out 30
minute times and part of it's knowing
you don't know if you're ready until you
do it as well until you do it so
definitely a good point I'm just saying
on a regular if you're trying to get
booked at your like home club and
they're like do you have 20 minutes to
feature and you have 20 minutes of
material just know that to Joe's point
if your material doesn't hit
you still gotta finish out those 20
minutes
which is the reason you want more time
right so I was just you know proceed
with caution
I'm just very careful because I know
that Bookers are looking to see if you
can do that time you know what I mean so
yeah
but yeah that makes sense
and I know I know we're going over but
there's one more that I think let's
let's do it can we squeeze this last one
and we'll keep we'll keep it tight
because we're literally like all right
we're doing a countdown timer and we're
sticking to it
but we did start late we'll tell our
wives we started late
um and hopefully no one will be late
after Valentine's Day
um wait a minute
clean show Joe
um some people are trying to be late
that's facts true
foreign
but the final one
um real quick from Clyde Williams and um
I these are from our Facebook group
we're gonna do this every week in there
and answer your questions here live on
our weekly live streams on our YouTube
and Facebook group every Tuesday at 5 PM
eastern time so do post your questions
in there on the thread you will see it
and um it's just super relevant to right
now Clyde Williams asked how much of
your stand up should you put online for
everyone to see
you know I I would say
when people started posting online which
I think it was probably more during the
pandemic
I was not a fan of like everyone posting
all their material online because I was
like what am I gonna go watch you for
but then I realized that I'm a comedy
nerd I'm a comedy fan I didn't want to
see everybody's material but most people
that go to comedy shows as I've learned
as a producer and I've produced tons of
shows probably hundreds of shows
it's like the first time coming to
comedy they probably haven't seen you
and they probably aren't going through
the list of all of your material
I think at this point I've sort of
changed in watching other Comics put as
much stuff as you possibly want out
there
like put it all out there whatever
you're comfortable for the world to see
to you know in essence they are judging
you based on that material and if you
feel good about it by all means put it
out there but I'd say that just took me
to last like two years to sort of shift
over to the other side because I also
understand marketing
you have to market the algorithm for the
algorithm to sort of feed you back
there's tons of comics that I knew that
blew up just from all these
um all the posts that they had and now
are getting bookings because of all the
posts and they posted all their jokes
but you know what they do at their show
they got more jokes
that's another way of pushing you
to where people aren't listening to your
joke from Tick Tock or from Instagram
they're coming to the show and they're
getting new jokes another good way to
sort of push you in terms of your
material as well
mm-hmm
yeah and something just to keep in mind
whatever you post just make sure it's
something that
[Music]
you don't mind living forever
so just make sure it's something you're
proud of that in five years you're gonna
be like oh that's embarrassing or like
oh maybe I shouldn't have done that I
mean just put yourself through that like
checklist of like is this something that
I like care to be out there forever you
may say I'll delete it later
but if it's on the internet it could be
there you know it may be there forever
uh if yeah forever so just keep that in
mind with whatever you post just make
sure it's something you don't mind
living on forever that if I if I look
back on this in five years would I still
be proud of this or would this offend me
then or just
I'm not saying to post or not post
things but just being mindful of once
you post it it's out there forever and
that is like Yoshi said
that's how people are going to see you
at the end of the day that's how a
Booker is gonna see you
so it's personal preference on what all
you want out there
but just be mindful that once it's out
there it's there forever so
I think uh when I interviewed Steve
Byrne which um will release soon his
take on this because we talked about
this
was
um he's like I don't think comedians you
know and he's been doing it 30 years
he's an old school guy he's like I don't
think comedians should release anything
until they're 10 years in and they have
stuff they can be proud of he's like
because the stuff you create three years
in you're gonna hate when you're five
years in and this fifth grade at five
years in you're gonna hate when you're
seven years in like and I can tell you
my personal experience
that's that's true for a lot of jokes
you're like oh what was I even thinking
or that's dumb now or what that's not
even Who I Am anymore
but
it's it you know it's a it's a different
era so you know I think I also heard
Louis CK talking on a podcast about
you don't have to serve the social media
algorithm he's like you're trying to
appease like
um you're trying to appease a computer
instead of an audience
and that's great that he just sold out
Madison Square Garden and that he
doesn't need social media
but Comics now I mean that's like it
it's kind of part of the job but I will
say for me I didn't even think about
promoting myself until maybe
six or seven years in when I felt like I
had something worth promoting I think I
had an act that I was actually proud of
that I felt was worth marketing and
getting paid for on a consistent basis
now I know people who blew up on social
media killing it making a living didn't
wait that long you know a year in
they're on Conan or whatever so
it's all personal preference like we
said at the beginning of this there's no
right way there's only your way so it's
just kind of at the end of the day
listening to yourself and what you think
is best for you and deciding from that
boom
so we're doing this every week we're
posting these uh a question thread in
our Facebook group or we also do a daily
joke writing contest
and uh if anyone wants to help us
start posting these as a podcast to
where you can like keep track of the
questions asked and um create show notes
and like a title for it and help us
upload it we will pay you to do that hot
breath the verse so that's where we're
at now and so and it's gonna be more
than a Super Chat that's what we can
guarantee that's more
that's a good point so anyone if anyone
watch this
um live and want to help out with us
that let us know or if you're listening
to the podcast version you're like oh
that's something I'd like to do
then uh shoot me a DM oh Mary said I
will get to your inbox bro okay cool
so yeah we do this every Tuesday at 5 PM
Eastern Time
thank you guys so much for listening
this was our first of many to come hot
breath lives
yeah what do you think you like this
I do like it uh I think obviously we'll
change it up in the future and have some
more feedback time but these questions
are great man like I Love How Deeply
like delved into each one and you know I
think these are the questions that I
know I get asked like
when I go to an open mic right like when
I'm like up there and I'm like trying to
practice for something people are like
oh
you're from the feedback Mike could you
could you answer a question for me like
absolutely
yeah exactly I love it so yeah thank you
thank you everyone for hanging out with
us happy Valentine's Day Happy
Valentine's Day Love Is in the Air
people
absolutles and we love you all so much
and we will see y'all next week Tuesday
at 5 p.m Eastern Standard Time
bye